the ink is barely dry on the new
sweeping tax bill and Congress is
already knee-deep in another fight this
time to avert a government shutdown this
weekend President Trump thinks Democrats
are trying to force one to take
attention away from the tax victory
House Democrats want to shut down for
the holidays in order to distract from
the very popular just past tax cuts
House Republicans don't let this happen
pass the CR today and keep our
government open Nancy Pelosi is a third
party to vote no unless Democratic
priorities are addressed we have
problems with this bill we do see it as
an opportunity for them to at least
allow a vote least allow a vote on
dreamers which we think we would win but
hopefully we've made some progress than
in there thinking that up as to the
urgency of it the house is narrowly back
to a short-term spending bill a first
step in averting a shutdown at midnight
tomorrow the Senate still must vote so
Dana do Democrats have any leverage here
at all or not not much no not with you
have majorities where you have the
Republicans able to pass it in the house
it was narrow I think it will just I
think it's gonna pass in the Senate I
don't think this is a great way to
govern we go through this quite often
over you you have a spending bill and
then it's a game of chicken for who's
gonna be blamed for a government
shutdown I don't think that's going to
happen everyone is able I think they're
able to get it done the big sticking
point for the Democrats was the dreamers
issue had already conceded that they're
going to have to deal with that in the
new year and in fact president Trump's
deadline wasn't even until March so
they've got some time so he extended the
deadline for the dreamers and they're
gonna put that into the immigration
overhaul I think that's what they hope
okay so if they do shut it down which
they won't but if they do Brian some how
will it be the Democrats shutdown
because you almost always Republicans
get blamed yeah because they're in the
majority i watch Nancy Pelosi say a
pretty compelling argument saying we
don't really have the power in either
chamber nor the presidency how could you
possibly blame me which is true for
Republicans got on the same page there
would be no problem however we're
looking to watch January 19th that
we're gonna have an extension to the log
do you do that you're just giving
leadership the chance to tell everybody
where they spend as opposed to
membership so why can't they get
everything in order starting B maybe
before January 19 to start putting
things through the committee process and
deciding how we're going to spend rather
than wait to the last minute and give it
to Mitch McConnell and Paul Ryan make
them eat it yeah what can't the
Democrats just let the tax cuts marinate
and let Trump take a victory lap why do
they have to go rain on his parade and
do the shutdown I mean it's just so mean
of them I so mean right mean-spirited
and the time of Christmas giving I don't
know it just doesn't make a lot of sense
it seems like they don't want to
acknowledge that this was a victor
they're gonna do what they can it's sort
of the you know the politics involved
here I'm its political sport back and
forth and so they're not gonna let him
have this they don't want to why would
they right because they want to say that
it's terrible that this was something
that's not good for the country and so
ultimately though Jesse I would agree
with you guys that I don't think that
they're gonna shut it down can you
imagine let's just shut it down and you
know over the holidays got the state of
Christmas Eve right I don't think so no
let's just count on that not happening I
think they're trying to divert attention
from the fact that they said all of the
corporate tax cuts were going to go to
all these fat cat CEOs and instead bunch
of companies Juan announced that they're
gonna give bonus checks to a lot of
their employees that doesn't really have
anything to do with what the Democrats
were telling us was gonna happen
what are you timing that's exactly what
the Democrats said that they we're gonna
give money back to the workers that's
exactly the opposite excuse me I'll
finish the point okay and then you can
start with the nonsense but that was
true know what you see and and you saw
today is a ton of companies saying oh
because of the tax cuts which is gonna
enrich our shareholders and our
executives oh yeah here's a thousand
dollar bonus to a lot of people right
that's good oh so that's fine okay all
right it's a result of the fact that
these companies made out like bandits in
this tax deal that's what so that's the
fact so you're against people getting
thousand dollar bonuses no it's a good
thing don't be foolish and don't mistake
what's going on here what you have here
is that the very rich got richer and
they say here's a little bit for you why
don't you take this sucker thousand
dollars it's not a little bit
terrifically unpopular remains unpopular
and if it comes to a shutdown right now
the Democrats have the upper hand why do
I say that because the Democrats have
public opinion on their side you have
Republicans who say let's pump up
military spending let's pump up the
deficit and yet they don't ever say
here's new sources of revenue in order
to balance a budget so whose there's no
talk about cutting spending let's throw
the sound by this is Sarah Huckabee
Sanders talking about what's going to be
on the agenda for 2018 we're working
through some of the top priorities I
think you can expect welfare reform
infrastructure immigration reform all to
be top of mind and something that
certainly we'll be looking at and
talking about a lot over the first part
of next year so what do you think about
those ingredients well I I think that
all makes sense your first year as
president is the year that you can get
the most unlike a slate of lead before
you head into the midterms and so with
the three big things that the president
can claim and in the tax bill yesterday
including the health care individual
mandate repeal and Anwar drilling which
is amazing for a Republican to get
through then where do you go from there
so I think that they're gonna have some
messaging problems on welfare reform if
they can communicate it in a way that
says we are wanting to reform the system
so that we can get people out of a
poverty trap and we this is the way that
we want to do that that would be it's a
good message it's hard to do when the
other side of it would be you just gave
corporations employment and wealthy
people all this money and now you want
to take benefits away from the poorest
among us how dare you I mean that is a
that's a tough messaging thing
absolutely but I don't know how they do
it an infrastructure look the Democrats
really want it but here's a problem the
tax bill was supposed to be what gave
you the new revenue in order to do fund
the big new infrastructure plan but
because it got all screwed up and they
basically had to pay for that on the
side instead of the corporate side now
where are they going to get the money
they're even floating the idea of a gas
tax and if you want to hit every
American where it hurts it's a gas tax I
think that's problematic for them I just
used a bad word the last one on
immigration reform I think that is
actually the most plausible and probably
out of those three the most important
and I think they could actually do that
before March what do you think it's
immigration no doubt about it they're
already meeting right now in a
bipartisan way on the Senate side on
immigration reform doing it massively
there's very little pushback I
understand on chained immigration and
there's very little pushback on the
lottery system so if you can give him
border security will give you daca and
then maybe you're gonna do something big
and for those Republicans who say oh my
goodness amnesty down trouble go listen
I don't care go ahead hit me with it
I'll be the bad guy Paul Ryan you could
act frustrated Mitch what kind of throw
up your hands you know I'll take the
slings and arrows would you brought up
as a very good point now if not adding
to the deficit welfare reform would be a
bad message even though it's necessary
all these entitlement reforms should be
necessary but to go okay now let's go
into welfare for the poor people even
though you're reforming it to make it a
better country it would be not a good
time I because I think would be insane
to do that right now so Kimberly said
Brian's point daca amnesty trade that
off for the wall do you think that's
effective for the president like you've
got to be able to negotiate you got to
bring something to the table you want
them to go for this and to increase with
you know border security you're not
gonna do it unless you give them
something that's meaningful that is the
price of doing business whether it's
politics or whether it's just the
financial industry etc so he understands
that I think that it's something he
would be open to and reasonable about
because of his heightened interest and
desire to increase border security again
a really big banner item that he
promised during the campaign so he's
going to his list he's checking and he's
gonna find out which Democrats are
naughty or nice I just made that is
there anything you like everything is
nice agenda in 2018 one yeah immigration
I mean III had a column in the hill this
week it was I said I think the
immigration argument has shifted
especially after what we saw in Virginia
even Alabama where those issues were
front and center
people who were like now it's not
exactly going to push me over the line
the Republican candidates thought you
could emulate Donald Trump success with
the issue it's a little bit different
now but I mean to me the the thing here
is I think that Paul Ryan really wants
big entitlement reform not just welfare
reform I'm talking about Social Security
Medicare which are big slice gonna do it
the president has said he won't do it
but guess what Dana I think that's what
Ryan wants I think that's what a lot of
people in the freedom caucus want they
want to push that and as you guys are
saying and I'm so pleased to hear you
say it it's insanity right now because
most Americans see this as a giveaway to
the rich the tax deal and if you come
back with the budget and say oh yeah
we're gonna pump up defense spending and
now we're gonna smack down the elderly
and the poor and don't forget they've
yet to renew daca not daca but the
children children chip the children
health insurance plan and even
Republicans are saying this is a problem
by January 1st no plan and that is not
something that serves a nurse talked
about today I know it is on their mind
but we have got to talk about the opiate
crisis today again for the second year
in a row we have the CDC Center for
Disease Control telling us that
Americans life expectancy is going the
wrong way for the first time in just and
they and they point to opiate addiction
as being the thing that is increasing
the deaths and it's increasing the
deaths of young people in particular
young men yeah that is something we've
got to figure out I don't know what the
answer is I'll build on your point
because I was just at the border and
most of the Border Patrol says yeah we
had a problem with illegals but we must
have a problem with fentanyl right and
that's what's coming across the southern
border so it might be a complete circle
I will say this I want I think it's an
oversimplification in accuracy to say
this whole thing is a tax break for the
rich it really isn't
most of the people with money are
complaining they're not getting their
break that they thought they're gonna
get and when you look at corporations I
actually want a quote MIT Romney it is
people and there's entry-level jobs in
those places and there's an opportunity
to bring people back and the movie
industry of all things is going to
benefit maybe the most some become
curious they write any good movies I'm
not sure I will go where we're gonna see
it that you just say that they're rich
saying they're not getting enough to get
2% Oh Oh 37 to 35
oh my god richer people two walls yeah
they're rich I just can't
these are screwed he's a human being
the benefit is thing goes to the rich
and the corporation's and you guys still
want brains are made up of people that
are middle created jobs for those people
Brian that'd be great but this is not
that this is about rewarding
shareholders and the CEO responsibly
that would be the answer but if they act
responsibly they will spread it out grow
the company because they know so you're
saying to me trust the very rich the
rich will take the poor person ever
given you a job thing is a very
important point if you see corporates
and you kind of demonize them but the
bottom line is is that there are
families like individuals at all levels
of corporations in support working in
staff etc so why do you want to progress
them an opportunity to do something to
provide for their family and relief is
better than none at all right but do you
think that corporate profits in this
country are to record levels yes they
are how about the stock market record
levels Oh give the rich more no the
argument is continue to improve on a
situation that has been very fortuitous
why not do it and why not spread it
around to the middle class - and they're
supposed to be able remember spread it
around